انا اولا في مدينه اصلاحيه في ولايه غازي
عنتاب هذه المدينه تقريبا نصف المباني
التي فيها دمرت وعشرات المباني
العشرات المباني الاخرى باتت تقريبا
للسقوط وغير صالحه للسكن نكبه كبيره في
هذه المدينه
يعني حقيقه اثار الدمار واسعه لا يمكن
وصلها هذه هذا المشهد الذي نصوره الان هو
حي بالكامل سقط انهار بالكامل بقي على
الارض لم يبقى سوى هذا البناء واقفا لكنه
ايضا غير صالح للسكن ستقوم السلطات
التركيه بهدمه بعد انتهاء عمليات البحث
حتى الان عمليات البحث ما تزال مستمره كما
تشاهدون نحن قريبين جدا من فرق الانقاذ
التي تحاول العثور على اشخاص ما زالوا تحت
الانقاض في هذا المبنى
التقديرات تتراوح انهم خمسه اشخاص لكن
الاعمال تستمر بالمحصله ما زال تحت هذا
خمسه اشخاص من ضمن هذا الحي الكبير الذي
نشاهده الان قد دمر بالكامل هذه النقطه
الوحيده التي بقيت
التي بقي فرق او المتطوعون وعناصر الفرق
الانقاذ ايضا هناك عناصر من الجيش التركي
معهم يساعدونهم في عمليات رفع الانقاض
والبحث هذه النقطه الوحيده في هذا الحي
الكامل حي كامل هذا البناء مكون من خمس
طوابق وهناك عده مباني مجاوره وايضا مباني
في الخلف كل هذا الحي انهار بالكامل فقط
هذه النقطه التي تعمل بها الان فرق
الانقاذ باقي النقاط قد تمشيطها بالكامل
والبحث بالكامل وجاري ازاله الانقاض من
هنالك فقط هذه النقطه التي امامنا هي التي
ما زال او ما زالت فرق الانقاذ تعمل بها